[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir
aujourd'hui 365e jours de pénurie de
pétrole
un an déjà nous avons vécu ensemble
année la plus longue
365 jours et 365 nuits de pluie de froid
de grisaille et de programme minimum
mais ce soir une lueur d'espoir nous est
permis
oui le pétrole qui repose au coeur de
l'himalaya
cette inépuisable gisement n'est plus un
rêve mais une réalité
[Musique]
en ce moment à gagny capital industriel
d'europe se déroule une réunion du cnpf
des images que vous allez voir vous
montre la gravité des circonstances ici
pour délibérer d'une affaire grave
notre avenir en dépend en effet sans
pétrole à quoi serviront tous les engins
perfectionné que nous fabriquons que
ferons nous demain veut nous retourner
en arrière et fabriquer des outils
dérisoire telles que machines à laver
est manivelle ballet bicyclette que
sèche où nous devenons entreprendre des
recherches scientifiques nous
permettrait peut-être utiliser l'énergie
solaire géothermique le vent la marée
choisissez et que ferons nous sommes
tous nos produits de toutes les
automobiles stationnées le long des
routes et le pouvons garder indéfiniment
tout et les carcasses je donnais ne sert
plus à rien ou non mais qu'elle
disparaisse prochain tour dans les
volcans
soyez patients là n'est pas le problème
nous pouvons les employés en
récupération
pourquoi la profonde et ue nous pas les
recherches qui avaient été faites sur le
moteur alcool cela permettrait d'écouler
les stocks de vins français
oui on joue et on pourrait aussi les
poulets stop de masse itanium
[Applaudissements]
rémy sont gênants que la véritable image
géante son pétrole eloignez-vous tous
vos problèmes financiers fauché à la
compagnie deviendra telle qu'elle est
elle une cinquantaine d'années enfin le
chemin des oiseaux pourraient s'élever
dans les airs sans être interrompu par
les bras sous 10 on notera pts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis le début de la pénurie
alimentaire
la population urbaine se ruent sur les
produits de première nécessité déjà
plusieurs magasins ont fermé faute de
marchandises
certaines grandes marques mondiales de
jus de fruit ou autres font faillite
pour manque de matières premières tous
ces faits sont propices aux nombreux
crimes qui sévit actuellement des
personnes âgées sont fréquemment
attaqués par des voyous sans scrupules
en quête de nourriture
comment l'agresseur est il entré chez
vous je regardais la télévision quand on
a frappé à ma porte j'ai ouvert sont
méfiés je n'ai même pas eu le temps de
dire ouf l'agresseur m'a frappé comment
était-il gants et masque et c'était un
jeune comment vous pouvez vous dire que
c'était un jeune puisqu'il était masqué
il ya que les jeunes pour profiter
qu'une vieille dame seule pour
l'agresser ces lâches
que vous at il volé ma dernière boîte de
sucre mada dernière de mercy souhaitons
à cette bonne dame un prompt
rétablissement sur la véloroute v3 un
carambolage a eu lieu il est dû à
l'imprudence d'un couple d'anglais qui
roulait à gauche un peu l'eau ton très
rapide n'a pu les éviter la catastrophe
afin de nombreux morts et des blessés
[Musique]
tous les cyclistes eux respecter les
règles de sécurité il n'y aurait pas
autant de morts et blessés graves sur
nos routes
et s'il portait au moins des ceintures
de sécurité tout cela ne serait pas
arrivé je vois quelqu'un qui me fait
signe vous avez une déclaration à faire
à la télé optik rythme on ne t'a gros
choc aujourd'hui 365e jours la pénurie
340 millionième père de baden la
campagne du bas de laine bat son plein
c'est surtout dans les écoles à la
demande du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qu'un effort particulier a été
fourni pour le succès de la campagne
[Applaudissements]
très bien les enfants
merci bonjour quel âge as-tu 13 ans tu
as l'air très en avance par rapport aux
autres
oui combien de paires de bas tu fais 150
c'est merveilleux mais où trouve-t-il
temps de faire tous tricot dans la
classe comme vous le voyez pendant la
récré et puis en regardant la télé mais
tu regardes quand même les feuilletons
au le feuilleton général e bof moi je
tricote je tricote qu'est ce que tu
ressens en tricotant ses paires de bas
je suis vraiment ému en pensant que
c'est bas pour ont réchauffé le coeur
des vieilles dames c'est vraiment
merveilleux de voir que tous ces enfants
travaillent de même coeur et de même
aiguille merci merci à tous ces enfants
les cotons et qu'autant français point
noir de la journée une nouvelle grève
illimitée dans les usines de radiateur à
10h aux revendications classiques
chauffer davantage les ateliers
[Musique]
bonjour mon coeur de place comme les uv
sont excités je suis maintenant dans un
couloir me direz je vais rêver ces
jeunes ne va pas vous inspire
aubin messieurs je vais d'apercevoir les
pdg ils ont tous des wild 2 autres c'est
l'infirmière la bct les monsieur je suis
malheureux je suis très malheureux les
ouvriers se sont mis en grève parce
qu'ils ont froid dans leur atelier de
pessah de grève sur un degré c'est quand
même supportable il fait 25 degrés dans
mon bureau c'est vrai j'ai besoin du
confort monsieur je dois garder la tête
froide
ils travaillent avec leurs bras salir et
chaud bon si je mets problème n'est ce
pas monsieur et le charbon est cher et
si j'ai attrapé un rhume ou si je ne
peux plus travailler qui nourrira ma
belle-mère ma femme mes enfants qui y
fera à marcher la fabrique un qui veut
manger qui très à plat et voulait
montrer ses sorties ce fol espoir qui
nous a saisis au début de ce journal
ce gisement de pétrole qui repose au
coeur de l'himalaya nous promet des
jours meilleurs
pardon m'apporte une dépêche eh bien je
suis désolé on vient de m'annoncer qu'il
n'y a plus de pétrole sous l'himalaya je
vous souhaite donc une bonne nuit
[Musique]
mais il est permis de rêver à un monde
sans pétrole
ça va oui ça va il vous sera mais ça va
merci votre mari sa ma wii les partis
travailler ce matin c'est au tour de son
groupe
il seconde il se repose il ne leur reste
plus de deux heures de travail à fournir
cette semaine et le troisième jean n'est
pas bon il faudra qu'on s'en occupe pour
vous en trouvez un troisième au revoir à
blanc à cette fois bonjour voisin jour
tu n'aurais pas un poireau pour ma soupe
un forum était ce n'est pas tout 10h58
tiendra trois ou quatre ian merci voisin
jolie matin toute la lumière
le joli matin nous met en train de me
les a réveillés vous il va falloir
remettre un coup de vrij à réveiller ou
aura ou du monde
encore un mètre et 2 et 3 il
83 des enfants seront fiers de toi la
roue de sera belle
[Musique]